Hey everyone.
A thank you. I didn't expect applause.
Well, thank you so much for joining me
today. I'm excited to speak with all of
you about, you know, some lessons I've
learned as I've been leading uh cla code
and co-work. So, actually, first I
should do an intro. So, yeah, my name is
Fiona Fun and I lead engineering and
product for cloud code and co-work. And
before Enthropic, I had also built and
led teams at Meta and Microsoft.
So, with that, let's dive into some
lessons I'm excited to share with all of
you. Hopefully, maybe you'll find a
couple of tidbits that may be helpful to
you.
So there are five topics I really want
to cover today. The first is the
bottlenecks have moved. And so when the
bottlenecks have moved and it shifted,
what are all the team norms that we
felt, oh yeah, we have to rewrite some
of these because it's changed. How we
rolled it out, I'll talk about like how
we rolled out some of these updated team
norms. And in terms of the proof, what
were some signals that I feel okay, this
has given me confidence that we're
trending in the direct right direction
and maybe it'll help you as well. And
lastly, I'll leave you all with maybe a
topic for you to all take back to your
team to discuss because I'd love to hear
about um yeah, whether any of this
resonated. So, with that, let's touch on
this first topic, which is the shift.
So, the bottlenecks have moved. And
you'll notice there's that little
subtitle there of what served you prior
may no longer. This is one of my
favorite sayings like actually I think
this is the muscle that has really
helped me whether at anthropic but also
before at the other companies always
being of that growth mindset like you
know from all the talks this morning you
see our rate of change is just
increasing and so I found it's always
helpful to look at what are either team
norms that you've set up for your team
or team processes and always ask
yourself is it still serving its purpose
so for years many years engineer ing
bandwidth was the expensive thing and
when you think about how did we all do
software engineering everything was
around kind of like protecting this
resource right like we want to do a lot
of planning because we want to make sure
when we're building that we have high
confidence that we're building the right
thing or we want to do reviews like
there's a lot of action around when
engineering bandwidth was a limiting
factor and maybe I'll pause there like
when you think about our industry this
is not the first time that the
bottleneck has shifted come I I'll take
you out back in a time machine with me
will go all the way back to the early
2000s. And if you all remember, so back
then I had just joined Microsoft. I was
working at Visual Studio. There was no
such thing as cloud. It sounds crazy
now, right? Like now cloud is so
ubiquitous, but back then there was no
cloud. And I remembered how we built
Visual Studio was this one server room
and everybody had to be on call for a
week and then you'd just go into this
room. And I remembered the whole build
process. It was a queue. we can only
merge six PRs at a time and anytime you
know one of the tests would fail you
have to debug which of those PRs caused
that failure. So back then that was
actually a big bottleneck and then now
with cloud and with continuous build
that bottleneck has also shifted. So
this is just another shift for us to
think about of when coding is no longer
the bottleneck, what changes
and so on the cloud code team, coding is
really the slow part anymore. And so
like that's why all the upstream and all
the downstream kind of like processes we
felt like we've had to change a little
bit.
So as an example, what were some of the
old bottlenecks, right? Like writing
code, writing tests, refactoring. In
fact, I'll share a story with you all.
When I first joined Cloud Code, I wanted
to on board and fix some bugs. And I
thought, you know what? I'm going to try
testdriven development. I remember that
was a really big thing a while back. You
know, the idea is write the test first,
make sure it fails, then do the change,
then now you already have a test. But it
was kind of like eating broccoli, you
know, like even though I actually really
do love broccoli, but I use as an
example. Uh, but I remembered you. It
feels like getting broccoli to write the
test first because it's not always the
most enjoyable part of the process. And
I remember always itching to build a
product and get to, you know, playing
around with it. And so now with Claude,
I remember the first bug. I'm like, you
know what? I want to try test-driven
development again. Let's write the test,
but first it will fail. Let's verify it
fails because that's how I could verify
the test is actually testing something.
And then we we you know, like I remember
like making the bug fix and then we
already had a test. And I remember that
first experience, test-driven
development was actually so much more
fun and so much more pleasurable. It
kind of took the tax out of testdriven
development. So that was a big aha for
me. Refactoring is another fun topic.
Like I don't know if you all have felt
this before, but you know, I've been on
teams before where we have to either do
like some big refactoring or some
software architecture cleanup. And it's
always a debate of when would we find
time to do this work? this work that we
know is so important but it always has
to come off at the cost of trading you
know time to build product. So again
thanks to the models and with claude
refactoring is also no longer a
bottleneck. So now when those shifts
happened, what am I starting to see that
as the new bottlenecks uh verification
that's a big one a lot of it's because
the bandwidth has just increased so much
we have to pay even more attention to is
it correct and I'll talk about this in a
little bit but also when roles are
blurring and more people are you know
checking in changes we also want to make
sure everybody feels confident that
their changes are correct who reviews
that's a really popular topic and also
how is it maintained And this one is
interesting because again the throughput
is now so much more also have to think
about you know the cost of maintenance
as well.
So these were some of the old processes
that we felt quietly stopped working.
And I love that phrase quietly stops
working because actually if I step back
anytime, you know, hopefully when
somebody puts a process in place, it's
to solve a problem. But very often we
forget to audit to go wait are those
processes still required or is it still
serving its purpose? So for example,
what were some of the things that we had
to change? planning norms when coding is
no longer you know the the the
bottleneck and and not like and you have
like much more coding bandwidth how did
we rethink through planning uh code
ownership is also another interesting
question almost all the claude code
commits now are also you know
co-authored by claude I don't think I've
in the last few months ever saw a commit
that wasn't a code review is a good one
like that's a lot of questions I get a
lot as well also team makeup roles are
blurring and what are the skill sets
that we're thinking, hey, you know what?
These are actually skill sets we're kind
of like doubling down into also
knowledge sharing. What happens when
maybe documentation is no longer your
source of truth? So given some of those
shifts, these are some of the team norms
that we had to rewrite.
We talked about code review uh and
actually cat this morning in the talk
really talked about clot code review as
well. That was a really like that's how
an amazing tool for us to make sure
we're all still doing the right thing.
Onboarding has also changed. I'll share
with you all my onboarding story.
Planning. I've talked about this already
of when coding is no longer bottleneck.
How does that shift our planning hiring
and also org shape org shape is a fun
one like you know we really want to keep
everybody more agile and flatter orgs
but every manager on cloud code actually
start as an IC first.
So with that how have our planning and
technical debates changed.
So in technical debate code wins you
know it's like building is cheap
argument is expensive. I'll actually
share with you all like I remembered you
know as I was onboarding I also want to
do some code refactoring. I was kind of
like hey what's some refactoring that we
think is good to do but we haven't yet
done. And I remembered me and Boris had
a couple of debates of approach and in
the old days I remember and I almost did
this. I almost said, "Hey, Boris, let's
just go to this meeting room and go to
whiteboard and whiteboard it out."
Almost did it. And I'm like, "Wait, if
if you know with thanks to Claude, I can
actually generate I remember generating
three different versions of the PRs."
And actually, that's what me and Boris
used to have a really good technical
debate because I wanted to not look at
how the code was implemented, but also
impact to the colleies. Uh prototyping
is another good one. So now like anytime
we're really having an idea, go ahead
and prototype and let's actually go
ahead and dog food it and then we'll
try. I remember many years ago also
having this uh prototyping conversation
in another team I was at um you know
because there was a debate there were
kind of two camps. One camp of
prototyping is great. It allows you to
move quickly to build you know kind of
like a war skeleton and get a feel for
the product. But on the other camp I
think there was a concern well you know
co prototyping you're kind of doing it
with speed. you're cutting corners and
there's concern of what happens when you
show a prototype that kind of works and
then you know maybe you get hung up on
it. You don't want to throw the code
away and then you end up trying to ship
that thing. It's not built to scale
again with cloud now actually
prototyping is a great way to get
started because we could iterate and
learn and then thanks to you know the
model's help we can also then actually
scale out a prototype to production a
lot faster.
So, what's one thing we reduce on the
cloud code team? It's, you know, I might
have been on teams before, maybe y'all
as well, like design docs, like really
in-depth planning and design docs. Most
of our discussions actually happen in
PRs or prototypes. And again, that's
just because the engineering bandwidth,
you know, is is now increased and coding
is no longer a bottleneck. Uh, what do
we really want to double down on?
Verification. And this is something that
I want to make sure you know me and our
team keeps keeps doing better as well
because now with all the bandwidth is
even more important to how do you verify
quality and I call this like you know
like shift left. So for example what's
better than you running it really sucks
for me when I hear from our customers
and developers and you all run into code
I'm always like ah I wish we caught it
first but you know what's actually
better than me running into the bug
first? Us having automation in place to
actually catch it closer to the source.
So that's like that's something that
we're really constantly looking at as
well of how to make sure we keep
shifting left and automating more.
Who made this change? This used to be a
question that a lot of folks would ask
of hey who who who was the last person
that touched this or who's a code owner
and now I encourage you all like if you
find yourself asking that question to
get to the root of the question like
what are you trying to answer? Is it are
you looking for someone that caused a
regression? Are you looking for someone
to answer a question? Are you looking to
gain context? And is there a way that
Claude could actually help you with
that? Uh Cat actually talked about
routines as well like earlier today.
That's one of the routines I have set up
like automatically, you know, in the
morning, I like over my morning cup of
coffee, I like to review all the
feedback in our various feedback
channels. So I have a routine that will
go through to kind of amalgamate all the
feedback for me and help me to identify
themes.
How do you keep up with code reviews
before we actually ship claw code code
review this was a question that I would
get all the time and now I can share
that answer with you all like definitely
cla code code review is one one tool
that has really helped us to make sure
we keep up with the coding bandwidth and
so where claude is really good right
like the style and lint obvious bugs um
anytime that you actually have like like
if if there is a spec I encourage you to
actually check the spec into your
codebase because cloud is very good
about verifying against spec drift but
it's still really important to still
have a human in the loop. So where do we
find even in code reviews it's really
important for humans still legal reviews
anything that it's actually about risk
tolerance. So especially when you look
at trust boundaries it's all about that
trust but verify and where humans bring
a lot of the needed expertise.
Product sense and taste is another fun
one. So last uh December, I wanted to
update Claude in our CLI to, you know,
give Claude a little holiday theme. And
I was ambitious. I wanted to turn Claude
into a snowman. I, you know, like I I
coded up an example and I asked her
designer, "Hey, can you go ahead and
review this for me?" And she gave me
such excellent feedback of, "No, this
looks nothing like a snowman. You you
you create you turn Claude into Mr.
Peanut. I don't know if Mr. Peanut's an
American brand." in in in the US we had
this jar of peanuts and you know their
their mascot is this little peanut
character and I was like holy crap
that's totally right. I I thought he was
a nomad, but you're right. It's a
peanut. And so that's where like humans
also like with that product sense, it's
really important to keep that expertise
in the loop as well.
Now, what should my team makeup be?
Because roles are blurring and clog is
augmenting. And so when it comes to
engineering, these are the two profiles
that I now really like focus on. One is
creative builders with product sense.
Um, and then another is deep system
expertise. And so this is definitely
like you know the hard parts want to
make sure that we can still have that
trust but verify maybe I'll talk a
little bit about product sense when I
gave the talk in San Francisco
afterwards a lot of uh engineers came up
to ask me a question of how do I build
this product sense muscle so I figure I
will share with you all of what I have
found helpful and it's helpful for me
and maybe it will resonate with you all
like for me it's this muscle that you
build with it first starts with dog
fooding and especially for managers
actually like making sure you're
spending time using the product that
you're building and your team is
building. In fact, most of the time
anytime I join a new team like that's
one of the first things I do. I'm like
dog fooding the product to make sure I
understand it because this way you
really start feeling your product in
your bones and you remember you always
ask yourself wait when I was building
this product what problem were we trying
to solve? Like what experience was I
trying to enable for our users? So with
that in mind like dog fooding is a
really good way especially for managers
who before cloud you may not have time
to be in the codebase anymore. Um but
yeah like actually anytime I joined a
team and I with dog food a lot of team
members would always come up to me and
say it's so awesome to see you using our
product because you really care because
that's a way for you to experience the
work as well. So for me product sense
comes from a lot of dog fooding and then
also like iterating shipping and then
going out to speak to customers. One of
my personal passion projects is working
with small businesses. I love small
businesses. I feel small businesses are
the lifeblood that forms our community
and we actually just announced Claude
for small business which is a project
I'm so excited at. Um but I have a lot
of friends that run restaurants and and
they work incredibly hard and so I met
with a lot of them to onboard them onto
co-work because I wanted to see how you
know like outside of enterprise with
small businesses how do our users
actually on board and I got such
valuable feedback. It's actually really
humbling to see we're in the onboarding
flow. we there were so many things that
we could have been doing better. So I
really encourage you all to to dog food
your product so then you really I call
it like feeling it in your bones because
it really keeps you um giving you a
sense of what your product is doing. If
not after a while you might find
yourself making product decisions that's
all just based on either metrics or
dashboards or powerpoints. So definitely
dog food dog food dog food or as we call
anthropic ant food.
So fill in cross functional gaps with
cloud. This is interesting because I
actually see this for all roles. So for
example, designers on cloud code team
previously you know anytime we wanted to
make polish or UX fixes designers would
go ahead and create that red line and
then hand it off to engineering and it's
always a wait, you know, because
engineering is always about I have to
build this product, I have to fix this
bug, when will I time to actually do
this polish. designers on cloud code
actually, you know, use cloud to make a
lot of those polish fixes. So then it
really closes that iterative loop a lot
faster. And again, this goes into why
it's so important to do the
verification. On the flip side, for me,
like for example, one time I was fixing
a bug and I needed a little bit of
content help. I I don't know about you
all, but as an engineer, I tend to be
very verbose. And when I'm like, you
know, if you ask me to write a very
short sentence to describe what
something's supposed to do, I tend to go
too much into the weeds. But Claude was
a really great content design partner
for me. And so that's what I found
really interesting on cloud code team
for all roles. Claude is actually
augmenting uh all the areas where you
may not be as strong.
So this was the manager slide that I was
like, "Oh, this was, you know, maybe a
good spicy topic, but when I first
joined cloud code, this was one of the
first things I changed of like, hey, I
was working with a recruiting team to go
because I believe so much in dog
fooding." And on cloud code, we're using
cloud to build cloud, we're using cloud
code to build cloud code. And so every
manager started as an IC first. I
actually felt this worked really well
because it enabled managers before you
have to worry about the responsibility
of supporting people actually having
time to, you know, like roll up your
sleeves and get into the codebase and
learn what it's like to be an engineer
on the team. Um, maybe I'll also, you
know, like touch on this is also a great
time that if you're a manager to
actually get some maker hours back and
actually get back into the codebase
because the onboarding is a lot less
daunting than it used to be. Um actually
even before anthropic there were
different roles I've had where I've
switched between manager and IC and I
think every time I switched to an IC it
really helped me build up the
engineering toolbox but that onboarding
was always a little like you know that
slight hesitation because it could be
daunting if you haven't done it in a
while but like speaking for myself I
remember when I onboarded to claude it
was uh it was such a different
experience and actually that's what
we'll go into next. So in terms of
knowledge sharing what becomes a new
source of truth. So when I was on
boarding to claude the code is our
source of truth and so again like in the
old days anytime I join new team I'd
meet with all the engineers to I still
do meet with all the engineers on the
team but now we talk a lot more about
what's on top of mind and because before
I would always so like do these tech
deep dives and now I actually did my
first you know like tech deep dive just
with Claude like because Claude has is
really good at answering all these
questions I have. So even when I was
doing that first bug fix, I remember
asking Claude, hey, before I dive into
this bug fix, can you actually teach me
a little bit about the surface area and
also what what about all the areas
around that bug as well?
And so for cloud code and co-work team,
our code is a source of truth. I would
encourage all of your teams like if
whatever is your source of truth where
whether it's a spec you might actually
change that into a skill that you check
into the codebase like whatever you can
make sure becomes your source of truth
keep in the codebase because this way
you can actually keep it up to date
because that's the other thing when
coding you know bandwidth is so much you
know like so much more it also makes it
easier for any documentation that also
doesn't isn't part of the update loop to
get out of date.
So how did we roll out all these changes
on the cloud code team? There were
things that we was really important that
we aligned as a team and then there was
also I want to make sure we also give
space for bottoms up because each team
is focused on different things and there
might be you know like different tool
chains or anything that resonates more
with each team. So what did we align
with kind of like the teams as a mustos
these are some of our cloud code team
principles and what we call forcing
function and this slide is out of date
like I shouldn't put every engineer it's
every teammate uses cloud code and also
co-work actually so like us using our
product day and day has been really
important quadify everything we can and
so like anytime we have a question of
you know what yeah I'm doing this what's
better than me doing it can cloud do it
for me because then it actually frees up
more of my bandwidth for other problems
to solve. And my last one is explicit
permission to kill old processes. Again,
it's the e even our team principles and
even processes that we put on even after
a few months when we notice, hey, is
this really serving its intended
purpose, we really always give ourselves
permission to always critique and make
sure to always revisit and but bottoms
up there's a lot of freedom for you know
like you know team or pods to adapt. So
for example, how cloud shows up in team
triage or any teams like planning
rituals or standups or which workflows
get cloudified first that is a lot of
bottoms up. So I found that this balance
of make sure you align with the team in
terms of like what's important in terms
of team culture and also update those as
you go but then leave some room for each
pod to adapt.
So if I zoom out what were the three
things that I prioritized for cloud code
and co-work that I think has worked
really well. Uh number one it was you
know like keeping the org agile and as
flat as possible having managers also
you know like support pots of work but
like also really get into the codebase
and be directly responsible for parts of
the product as well. Uh number two
that's quadify so if cla can do it
claude should. So that's always a
question we're asking and and maybe
that's the other interesting too like um
you know this morning you heard the
talks about the models the models are
improving at an amazing pace. So
sometimes we might find even if cla
wasn't good at doing something two or
three months ago now with like a model
update it's actually gone really good.
And this is why again it always goes
back to that whole like always revisit
and always have the growth mindset
because the models are also improving
really fast. And again, you know, people
don't delete processes on their own.
They tend to pile up. I remember I was
in a team where we had so many different
SLAs's. There was an SLA for P 0 bugs,
an SLA for incident response. And after
a while, I'm like, with all these
SLAs's, I need a stacked rank list to
actually have because even the engineers
are coming to me going, there's only 24
hours in a day. Like, which SLA am I
supposed to do? And but that's why it's
always so important to audit. I remember
at that time, I'm like, you know what,
we really should be auditing. Are all
these SLAs still really necessary?
So now for the proof, what are some
signals that we're seeing of like is it
actually working? So these are some
numbers that I find as helpful that I
wanted to share with you all. And so
these were some of the shifts we've seen
as we've been kind of uh improving our
workflows. Onboarding ramp up time goes
down. Like I I think that's actually a
really good signal of uh like we used to
have this thing of like what's the span
of time it takes for the engineer to
land their first PR the onboarding ramp
up time and also like cost to other team
members we've noticed keeps going down
like I I I even like a lot of times
sometimes when a person joins a team
they'll ask me a question I'm like
that's a great question we should ask
Claude like that's how we kind of uh
like Claude has really helped us to
onboard and answer a lot of questions
which is also why for the managers I
it's why it's fun for me to actually get
back into the codebase. Cuz in the old
days, I would actually feel bad because
I feel like, oh, I need to learn this
area. I'm going to ask an engineer and
take time away from their day because
they're all so busy. But now, thanks to
cloud, I don't feel like I'm wasting
anybody's time. The PR cycle time should
also go down. But this one's
interesting. I'm going to say it's
important for you to not just look at
the end to end, but actually break it
out into like what are all the different
funnels in terms of a PR? Because if
your PR cycle time isn't going down, it
might not mean you're not adopting AI.
It could be other parts of your queue is
actually getting jammed up because of
all the throughput. So for example, are
your build and CI systems keeping up? So
for PR cycle time, I think it's actually
really healthy to break it down into all
the different chunks and seeing which of
those you might be able to improve or
automate. And lastly, claude assisted
commits go up. As I mentioned, I don't
think I've ever like in the last few
months, I've not seen a commit that
wasn't uh you know like assisted by
Claude. But if I step out like I would
say what's even more important than just
throughput is whatever you know you and
your team are trying to solve whatever
the product or problem find some way to
measure that because outside of just
throughput hopefully we're also making
meaningful change to make the product
better or improve quality.
Okay. So now it's time for me to maybe
share like a little takeaway home
exercise that might be fun for you to
take back and go have discussions with
your team. But first, I want to be
really transparent. I still have
questions as well. So, I'll share with
some of those that we're still working
out through the cloud code team. So, for
example, do you still need separate iOS
and Android orgs? Like that was kind of
like more of the traditional org
approach of you would usually have like
one for iOS, one for Android. But now
with cloud and enabling our engineers to
go flex across different mobile
platforms, we're thinking, hey, do we
really still need the, you know, two
separate mobile teams? uh how far do you
push fully automated reviews? We always
want to make sure we're striking that
right balance between kind of speed and
fast enough and make sure we're not
losing something important
and roles are blurring and how do we
make sure everybody is productive and
that's why we're we're right now looking
through verification is a big one so
that hey as we're going through make
sure everybody that makes a change has
confidence in their change but also what
are all the different parts of the
workflow too like I'm working with my
designers we actually just you know
announced claw design also thinking
through how can we make sure that we're
also improving the workflows of all the
functions on the team.
So with that, this is what I would love
to leave you all with. Pick your
noisiest workflow or it could be just
some workflow or team meeting that you
don't particularly enjoy or it's really
high tax on the team. Like I remembered
I was on another team where we would
have this really expensive weekly
meeting and I noticed everybody's on
their laptop and you know except for
when they have to pop their head up to
give status and then they go back to
their laptop. I'm like, is this is when
you count, you know, like how many
people's in this room? This is a very
expensive room. So, always like kind of
like pick a workflow and always ask
yourself, is it still serving its
purpose? Or if it's like really
expensive, is this something that Claude
might be able to help you with? And kind
of like do this one step at a time.
And with that, thank you so much for
listening to my talk. It's been a
pleasure.